you
[Music]
hi everyone so we will get started I
think people will come gradually yeah so
so today we are very happy to have
Justin here so Justin is from Georgia
Tech it's not a pitch first year PhD
candidate I think no it's very 50 year
already
so 50 year candidates his adviser is
David Patrick and he's very famous for
his kind of work on vqa his kind of the
initial kind of effort can I initial
contributors and the author's fully
evacuate task and then he has done a lot
of interesting works envision language
intelligence for her for example say
vision and the language side so today we
are very happy to hear about what's
going on recently in Justin store in
Justin's research
so let's welcome Justin thank you and
thank you printing for instruction and
it is really a great pleasure to talk
here so a lot of work I've been doing
the last few years involves the question
how to understand and generate like a
granny language so together since what I
mean by there let's consider this image
if you ask to describe this image it
made something like a kitchen a clean
kitchen with a double sink a black
kettle on staff and refrigerator we are
reading the sentence you may ground it
the words in the in this sentence to a
specific region in the image and if you
want to know more about this image you
can ask the question something like is
there anything in the sink and if you
focus on this region you can get the
answer it is a wash clothes and you may
want to know more about the color of the
wash clothes and the answer is blue and
it's actually happening a dialogue here
so and we can actually get in some
informations by this kind of interaction
or communication and the general
research problem we are interested in is
how can we available an agent to this
kind of grounded I call it coming
occasion and interaction about the
visual environment so a common approach
is to collecting a data set for each
task for example we can collect cocoa BQ
a Dara log data set and we can train our
agent to do this kind of data set well
if you decorate your kitchen a little
bit more so our agent may face a much
more great challenge for example it may
it may never saw an elephant is standing
on the shelf so it may recognize this is
a cup but what does a second mean here
so those actually those stickers making
the leaf let's look like a refrigerator
though this scenario is a specific
instance like some like what we call it
an open world wronging problem so namely
it is impossible to collect or tunings
that that contain all the concepts
within country every day and the
question I'm going to answer in this
talk is how to leverage grounding learn
from other sources to improve the multi
model AI tour capability so I'm going to
talk describe two projects which trying
to solve this in two different
perspective and there are lots of
interesting applications related to
vision language so for example like
visual like developing a visual or like
virtual assistant helping visually
impaired and machine teaching and
explained away I so there are some other
previous work I'm interested in general
so something like vqa image captioning
and the visual dialogue and image video
understanding and embody agent so that's
basically covered on my previous
research your my PhD okay so let's start
it so my will consist on this to
project the first line is near Baby Talk
is published on CPR 28 and it's mainly
for generation and the second one is
filbert appreciating tasks cannot
distinguish the feature for vision
during our business and tasks so he's
found this year need and then is going
to many about understanding so image
happening probably something like people
in this room may like not already know a
lot so to me this is kind of
mental capability of our agent to
describe what is things in here so for
example give me of the input desire of
the desire the desire output is to
describe this image for example in the
left image it is a table has a mark and
a plate of food on it and on the right
is a dog dogs wearing a goddess and
leather sitting on a motorcycle so
existing state of art English captioning
system mainly consists of this two
component a collusion your network which
extracts visual features and a recurring
Network which generate the captions so
let's look at a bottom-up and top-down
attention from each caption English is
actually developed by Peter like during
intern in MSR and it consists it's using
a detector approach individual genome to
detect two representative in features
and it has this kind of to layer our
stem visitation to generate captions and
let's look at some result for example
give me the first image it can generate
something like two elephant and the baby
elephant is walking together it's
actually pretty great and you can
generate something like a cat is
standing on a sign that says something
and a man standing on a beach holding a
surfboard and notice that it is actually
not perfect so we don't want say some
awesome and token like this is actually
not informative and this actually is
beyond the capability of the captions
caption system and also there may be
something something like a bias here so
it's actually a clock not a softball so
if we check the output of the object
detection and OCR system so we can see
that it actually did correctly
detectives like the signs and signs
coming up the sign and also this is the
clock here so an idea in which caffeine
system should directly borrow these
those concept detected by other system
and ideally we want to correct it this
time token to to like to the to the
actual content and that and replace the
circle to the clock
and let's take a step back by looking at
some image caption system before the
deep learning revolution so baby talk
for example use a deform like the DPM
which is a very old-style detector to
detect the object attribute and
prepositions and then it is a like a CRF
Network this leads to joint refine our
joint predict the labeling and then if
we're going to feel those kind of
detected concept into this human general
template so for example like this will
be generate caption like this is a
photograph of one dog and one cake so
every sentence will look similar and if
we compare this to different system we
find that the baby talk approach is more
grounded because it is it has a caption
with detected output
well the fit of our newer based image
caption system is more natural because
it can generate potentially like many
captions and the ideal system is
something in the middle so we want it
can associate the name thumbs up to the
pixel and Bunny box detecting the image
and we also want human generate we also
want no human general template we want
language needs be natural and this
exactly what we are designing for for
this image caption system ok let's look
at the model in more detail though given
an image we it can use arbitrary
proposals from any object detectors and
to express some features erect region
features so by introducing a novel kind
pointer based like recurring you into
work our model can generate this kind of
like story caption completion like
something like yellow box a yellow
region with the grey region is sitting
at blue region with a green region and
then we are going to filter slot by
using the concept find by the detectors
and the final caption is the composition
of these two so Beasley it's the final
caption knob can be a puppy with that
highs is sitting at table with located
okay the first question is how to
construct the caption complete
and given this image a young woman
standing next to a man holding a
softball we can use some kind of
auxiliary annotation such as detection
so we can we have this kind of an
annotation like the person there is a
person there's two person here and there
is to preserve wall here so we can find
we can matching these person labels with
the words in the caption buys by kind of
stream match and then like we can find
like so she ate person labels to each
words in the caption and if we remove
those nuns so Ashley there is the
template here and if we are able to
remove more something like attribute and
actions we can get a more abstract
complete you can see his offline process
but in natural like we are producing it
I like online during the training so we
are considering a lot of different yeah
yeah this is this is offline yes
inference time is actually little bit
different that you just check or we have
a named entity recognition to see yeah
yes also in this paper we actually don't
have this attribute stuff we're only a
focus on the nuns but basically we
giving a person we have a dictionary so
piece layout by available are we
introducing later part but this way we
have a dictionary and map mapping the
words to getting the critics of the you
need to play the video captioning and
reissue image this engine is based
Peters world no no this is like giving
shoes yeah okay in the training stage so
yes if there's some problem we are
facing so yeah yeah just the in the
later slice okay so let's look at some
model details here so basically we are
using a pointer network with visuals and
you know so generate the captions
template so we may focus this is
actually the region features
and this is the Sentinel vector which
basically represent what is the model
already know about the caption and give
me the word a here we want to generate
the network YUM so basically this will
refer to the Sentinel vector and given
the next word we want to with rearmed
generally these regions so it will
actually referring to the actual region
it's pointing to yeah and actually this
is the answer for the question like
because we may because like different
for different image may we may have
different that of the detection system
maybe not perfect so for example given
look at this image like a maze playing
guitar on stage because of this bad
illumination right the detector output
is actually something like umbrella
shirt and card right so we don't want to
use any of this output for our caching
system so our solution is to treat this
object labels as caption template so so
basically so if we can treating this the
template as a man is playing a guitar on
stage the system fall back to a normal
English caption system right so there's
actually no visual wrong in here how I
do this is waitin ethically identify the
visual word during training so basically
we are having these rules so like like
the intersection over Union of the
detective burning balls and chip and
grant responding box is locked from
point five and the detect labels is
match the worse then we are treating it
as a slot or visual word here
so because we're having involved this
Detective bounding box the model can
kind of know if this is a bad demon
nations the detectors detection system
may be bad so then if you're not using
any of the detections output cool and
the second stage is filling the slots so
for example given this template we
already generated a young like rich into
standing as the written story holding
region five and also visit detection
output with this kind of concept
cost concept we first do a like
classifies a priority and basely give me
a person amount of classify this is a
single not plural and the second is well
who defined the fingering character here
so give me the person class we want to
classify this is a woman and the final
output is a composition of history and
let's look at the objective function so
basically we minimize across energy laws
of this big objective function but it's
actually pretty simple and we minimize
the template were probability and we
also this this heart minimize the
refined refinement probability and also
this target region probability so you
may notice that we have an average term
here so that is because we have
different co-reference when different
kind of supervision exists right so
let's look at this image and for example
caption is a young woman is sitting
inside a boat so there's only one young
woman but their mind might be multiple
boat here because kocoum providers which
boat is the target one and and we and we
may not don't know like which boat is
referring to so our solution is to
maximize average target region
probabilities here so and if we're
having this supervision we can simply
maximize the correct one and so let's
look at some data set so we provide like
which we know almost sound like flickr
to be k encode data set and like we also
build this object category to worse so
basically i falco : is something like
person is mapping to child Baker so any
concept we can find and also we have has
a normal caption processing steps here
so sums result here so for standard
image captioning like we compare the
Flickr study K and Coco so we can see
that our model is achieve the set of
state of the art at that at that time
and by comparing the like by providing
the grounds with bounding box as a blue
one
so we also observed like it's actually
improving a little bit so that means
that our model can benefit a more
accurate of a detector we also proposed
this robust image captioning tasks
so the goal here is to evaluate image
captioning for normal scene composition
right for example in this case the cat
and monetary something like less less
less cooker in in the Coco image so
basically like our split has this kind
of properties the dispersion of
co-occurring object entrained data is
different from test data and then we can
have the sufficient examples from each
caption twin and we have this normal
composition of pairs of categories in
test this is just split just kind of
greater speed here and then we can
evaluate this a new metric called
accuracy is obviously basically like a
weak waiver can you value whether or not
a generic caption includes a new object
combinations so basically it's not a new
object which is a new combination the
normal object captioning and the normal
image captioning really want to say okay
you already know this but it's less
conquering so and we were busily
creating this split to make sure that
that's a composition of this test is new
well it's not a Coker integer and this
is a result for the size of this
training train and yeah it's so easily
there's no data here we just the
building is split by kind of this like
using this kind of like actually
actually like I think the test data will
will consist of the trend here so so
like this Li it's just a redistribution
of this yeah yeah huge caption you see
yeah so basically what we see here is so
this is like we're running our attention
attention uptown and no baby talk so
what we see here is that early that
compared to the like on the standard
standards that standard split if you
really like job to a three point on
those metric
and we also observed that our model
actually especially on those the
accuracy evaluation a model outperform
more like to a better job on this metric
and we also test on this unknown object
captioning and this is proposed by
earlier work and business ago here is to
describe the image with normal object
and though so but if I what to do is
that they exclude all the pairs that
contains at least one of the eight
objecting Coco so something like in this
image the bus is never shown in the
Train
and the test split is like a test the
test is split in two in domaine and auto
domain so intervene means that okay so
it contains those concept already seen
and optimized means is nothing so
they've evaluated on I've and score here
this is going to check if the excluded
object correctly mentioned in the
introduction and this is a result oh
yeah so so this this details that is
only like this list they are is in a
coup de main right so baseless they are
going to like a split the data set which
you don't see the you don't see the plus
here but no cap is actually in your more
open domain so it use the open image you
use actually more image and with more
character is yeah and yes this is the
performance and yeah and purely like we
are outperformed devoured as I said I'm
cool and in summary so we propose a
two-stage approach for image captioning
and it first generates a hyper template
and then it feels as lost with caption
of this character is recognized by
object detector well there are also some
limitations here so one limitation is
that it only grounded non words which
founded by optic detector so we can
extend it to attributes actions OCR's
which is making the most system more
like more powerful and the second is it
limited by the image caching dataset
right so we are still training on the
cocoa dataset so like that so the
solution may be something like we can
learn from other data
and this exactly I'm going to talk on
the Ness project is Wilbert we are
trying to leverage other like other
sorts of data to train this system cool
any questions okay and for the view per
project so basically we are trying to
explore this kind of general training
and fine tuning procedure on vision
language model on visual language tasks
so we have a very cool system for
something like image had a visual
question-answering image captioning
which becomes its reasoning and vision
language navigation right so a common
procedure is to collect a data set and
and design algorithm here oh sorry yeah
sorry and we and between our agent on
this on this data set so and we do this
I will repeat this kind of procedure on
every every class we are interested
right so it made some leave some issues
here so and because this procedure is
often resulting in a specialized agent
with limit scope of visual grounding
performing an aerial task and it is
really unclear that an agent working
well on vqa can working well on image
captioning so for example give me this
image and it's a question give me the
question like what type of a plant it is
so the agent will ask what was the
question the question bought enter bot
will answer banana
well the caption bot will generally
caption something like a bunch of red
and yellow flowers on the branch and
note that there is inconsistent here so
when we do want this concept visual
concept to be consistent so the co of
where interest is one to design a common
model for visual grounding and leverage
them on wide array of vision and
language tasks and so basically we want
to preach in the visual grounding so
note that the protein and transfer is
something existing in the post in the
like vision and the natural language
community for example in vision
community
like we have this image to the said
image net and so basically we're
approaching this on the class efficient
tasks and then we can fine tuning an
update detection semantics amputation
and post information but for for the LP
community we have this book covers and
they keep it here and we can have this
bird of activity elmo and then we can
fine-tune um question answering
companies inferences and signal analysis
so the problem here is what kind of data
do they use to learn visual branding so
in this in this project we are using
this episode called conception
conceptual caption data tag and it is
actually the image and caption pairs
collected from the website so for
example this image and so basically that
will convert from the annotation from
the all tests which busily is helping
the visually impaired and by some heavy
purpose missing it can generally caption
something like a pop artist perform as
festival in a city the merit is that it
is actually aligned image pair caption
is line image caption pairs and and then
we can learn visual bonding here so it
is large scale and approximately like
super points remaining data here and
also its automatic collected so we can
scale it very easily the next question
is what we want to put on the other side
of the box it's obviously the model here
so let's look as a bird model first so
this is a bird model taking two sentence
as input and if you're masking the
sentence and trying to retrain to
predicting this masking work here and
basically if you're trying to use the
contest contest information to predict
incidence and the simple solution is
that okay we can replace this sentence a
vis image and then like this kind of
paired data and we can masking the image
and we can predicting the we can
predicting the we can predicting the
reconstructed image or predict the words
here
in it we're going to in a generation or
will you just promise me you can
actually predicting something like a
like request teachers like to how to
minimize the distance between the
features something like this or you can
are predicting some highbury labels some
soft label soft copy yeah yeah and also
we yeah actually I'm going to talk maybe
later so here when you have two
sentences the way the whole system is
built what's going to take into account
the order of the words but in image you
don't the way you describing the
features there is no order yeah are the
two parts of the mold different yes yes
so for the image part we actually have
this location embedding here
so the location embeddings obviously the
words the word are in the sentence is
this is they have this kind of location
embedding and appending on the
interpretation so for the image part we
also have this embedding specific for 2d
to dimension
oh the nature obviously is that we embed
the coordinate of the like this is a
bounding box location of the image x1
yeah actually the yeah just a top left
and under various and haze and something
like a coverage in case of language they
don't do that in the format day but this
is harmonics yeah actually different
here yeah so so why not do the same so
because image is 2d right it's not
really clear how to do yeah so basically
there yeah there are actually many ways
to embedding them so and I think in our
word we are did really explore this like
which one is the best option but I
simply just think this is most intuitive
way I think but this is maybe try it
later to see right Oh which one is the
best so I don't have a really good
solution good answer no use those
psychos and
mr. position if you're learning the
embedding you're still learning the
vector editing better coordinate units
storing XY yes it would be high
dimensional representation of the images
yeah did you learn your very embedding
for first war ii were Spacely those
index and for image is just some kind of
embedding for for BBC's of vector maybe
a like a location vector X Y vector here
to convert to okay yeah and so the bird
architecture basically involved is
transformer encoder so basically it is a
multi head self attention and to model
model to model the Comcast and it is a
feed-forward layer it has feed-forward
layers to compute nonlinear here key
features and it is and it has layer form
and residuals to making the model
country a very deep and it also have
this position in weddings and which
allow the model learn relative position
and there might be some problem here so
so one of the problem we are thinking is
there's a different mentality may
require different level of abstraction
so for example for the linguistic stream
or the language stream given the word
artist so we have an embedding layer or
seem like a linear layer to projecting
them to attends representation but for
the visual stream give me the image we
actually have this kind of over a
hundred layer of convolutional network
to represent the features okay so like
so the weight is not the same or to the
truth as different and in this paper
like our solution is to treat them
differently so we really like proposes
to stream models which process select
which process visual and linguistic
separately so basically like we kind of
splitting this the bird model into left
and right side to note that there are
actually different parameters involved
on different side and so Alpert can have
our layers and Weber can have K layers
and and early the K is less smaller than
L they don't share the parameter yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly I'm going to
see it not nest so and then the problem
is how to feel different modality right
and our solution is use Co attention
which basely is proposed by my earlier
work to fuse information between
different sources and so this is exactly
a more complete figure here so busy you
are you can looking at this looking this
code each code transformer so and
basically it's going to extract the
information from the from the forms the
language tied to the two divisions into
the vision side and the quotients former
is is something like basely we
replicated it's a single transformer to
Malcolm like to the top one and and the
transformer encoder with query from
another modality here and we're going to
react aggregates information with
residual add operation so basically that
it's going to a granade information from
another modality at every every every
like layer and the protein objective
like we are since in these two so the
first one is masking multimodal labeling
modeling and it follows the mask
language modeling in Beart basically is
we like a 15-person of time the word
image regions come to predict and the
linguist stream involves is like kind of
replace masks can replace random word
and keep the same image regions you mean
yeah so yeah so in our wordlessly we are
predicting the soft labels so obviously
because you have a detection output
right and you have these soft labels so
I came to minimize the KL
KL divergence between these two
descriptions for the visual stream like
a Paisley way after 80 percent of time
replaced with a zero vector here vector
is actually the relation and now in some
labels is kind of the repetition
basically people used for I think it's
tooten 2048 so it's a rap station before
the label there's a linear layer
converting them to the labels so
basically are trying to mimicking this
linear layer the hope
yeah this pictures are from like a map
attention obviously is which is a
detector is a detector between our
videos you know so Peter and do them to
like proposes remark to attract interest
so you have image yeah yeah
we have image and you have a detector
and and the detector is putting down
like a view genome so this is a very
tense annotated annotated data set and
then you basically you have a detections
and those features are actually those
detection output basically the feature
of the detection this flow issue is
really that yeah yes yeah actually
actually is something like this
obviously obviously given this image so
it will detecting these different
patches and it is used yeah this is used
a fast start in with residual 101
backbone and you train on with your
genome data test
so it also has like this 1,600 1,650
tection classes so and so base is a
representation is for each bounding box
and so in are like in like what we do is
that we use the some of the region
embedding this location already so
location ban is what is kind before
well the test representations we are
using the same as a bird
so Bisley is that use this kind of like
30,000 word pieces vocabulary on input
it each token is some of these three in
beddings the the token embedding
segment embedding and finishing body
cool and let's talk about the fine Tunes
yeah so for the second embedding here so
for image for this we don't have that
we'd only have one second embedding but
for bird because it used the
consecutiveness right students here so
the first sentence will be one second
this will be true so base lead basically
indicated which soon is it is yeah but
in our case since we only have one
caption there secondly betting only use
one so there is actually not in learned
here
yeah yeah just people emailing for walk
for consistency mr. Burke yeah and yeah
and basically is a fine-tuning procedure
is going to protein on using the
objective where I'm just describing and
we are fine-tuning the forecast in this
paper no caption just yeah because we
want to be separating these two things
yeah
and on the fine-tuning we are having
this VQ a and basely is giving an image
and trying to ask the question ask a
question and this VCR basely give me
this image and the question you are
going to find the answer and the reason
so bases it has a nice property of tying
the specific like person with image
regions and well and also another one is
refer expression so given the teams are
like description you want to find the
christening regions and also the caption
base image retrieval so giving our
sentence caption you want to retrieve
the correct one from a pool and this is
some result so we compare with the sin
of Arc like a vq a and we see are the
times at time so it observes that our
model has a little improvement on vqa
they all have a similar improvement on
VCR and by comparing this single stream
with our to stream models we find they
are some improvement over here and if we
compare is without pre-training on
conception caption approaching on cam
subscription we also find that the final
model is as well perform like with
opportunity and this is a result for
refer cocoa and with you and the image
retrieval so in in general like we find
a really a Signum improving oversight of
our our data
i speaker yeah it's pretty here's a DK
and we also do this ablation study so
basically on to study because we have
this ability to vary the vision layers
right so we want to study okay what is
the most appropriate layer number of
layers we want to four different tasks
so they tried on two layer 460 and
8 layer so we can see therefore vqa
actually the six layer is better but for
VCR to layer can already do a pretty
good job so it's actually so there's a
difference AB small but actually the two
layers is actually can be better and we
also do operations on per tunic it's
obviously very is different returning a
number of paintings that specially we
use a 25% of the pre-training 50% pure
tuning and we observe this train set
like a very small data with marketing
data so downstream performance is better
yeah and and interesting is that
actually when they put the papers on
archives there is a whole line of the
concurrent work here so including like
including different like different labs
and different organizations and so this
is really a hot topic now
so people are kind of have same interest
at the same time yeah this is our paper
and in summary so we proposed a task
agnostic vision English we propose a
task analysis we linguistic
representations for Pratunam for visual
grounding and we introduces protein
transfer to vision language tasks we
achieve the Devourer a multiple vision
language tasks and and the limitations
is the motto can still learn in
consistency grounding by some tasks
listen fan tuning right so and then like
our solution is trying to trim out
provision language tasks together so
like it's not like cuspid even tuning
but you can fine tuning all of the minor
ones
okay Sunday okay the insistence is from
the hospital including yep and also why
you call this video quality because I
didn't say yep work
the bronies actually hybrid because
because like because of this / training
right you are trying to use one modality
to infer another modality please that
you are trying to collect predicting the
connectivity fits behind this so we have
some visualizations which I didn't show
here please Lee we see that by
visualizing the attention and we do
observe that the world are correct are
corresponding to the correct regions you
motivate your research yeah blogging is
the is my surface area pilot ask I
filter good results of every loss of air
results I don't know how much it's
attributed to the blogging history yeah
we're having any analogous to that Oh
yep we fix all the groaning you can you
put a performance by Sileo same image
yeah I don't make it rolling
yeah yeah I think that's a really good
question I think people their mind is
different tasks to specific values your
grounding something like re4 expression
right busily you are marrying whether
his phrase are refer it correctly right
but but for this kind pre-training we
actually didn't have a really good way
so we can only do by obstacle
visualizing like something like
visualize don't you retrain your with
yes I mean yeah I mean but I think in
this case yeah I mean that's that's a
pretty good way but we need to combine
these two modality at some point to do
this visual language tasks right and ii
see but we have we have tried it's like
without a new tradition like without
pre-training obviously we are using
train from scratch on this downstream
tasks and we actually observe our worst
performance here visual
they are referring the expressions yeah
yeah that is a specifically designed for
the ground everybody yes but but we
actually talked with if we actually
don't have the we actually don't have
like a specific way to evaluate whether
we are on / tuning stage whether we
learn better
yeah but we do observe on downstream
past is actually especially for refer
expression it actually have a really
huge posting up performance compared to
a pine cone as a separate ask I think I
think in general I think in general we
should do this because because I think
this may leading to a more interpretable
what is the network doing right but how
to do this in large-scale you can
imagine that we have sort of Oracle
study where you assume everything is
quality yeah please 100 say isn't based
on that you kept a caption yeah yeah you
see CDP a pool have you ever read such a
experiment
no no because I don't think we have the
labels and on top needs to be many
variable yeah just give me them or not
yeah I'm not wrong ten years is what
people are looking at much in
translation yeah the grounding is
another thing we can tell yes yes so we
actually develop this manually online
yeah but yeah then the issue that using
these menu around corpus we can view the
yeah much better
they just a translation yeah sister the
nut was the water on the sill became my
ask yeah they accuse here yeah what
alignment yeah yeah that's true
so actually like if in translation is
there some work basically trying to
injecting this prior because if you know
the alignment or work you're having some
prior right they are trying to injecting
the prior to the transition system and I
think they observed an improvement here
it is very useful in all the days where
people
no people move to dismiss I say to New
Orleans I so yeah where the attention
part is yeah Highbury Highbury yeah so
as many different version of a similar
question so um let's ignore all tasks I
just don't care about any of them right
most of what we've been talking about is
like oh this if I have enough of these
different tasks then somehow I can show
them all is this one model so therefore
it's the best model but really at the
best model because it's just seeing
those tasks so let's forget all tasks
for a second I'm interested in the
question of language grounding okay in
the in the model alright what it's doing
right is you've introduced this specific
cross modal transformer cell so where
what's what do i what if I learnt or
what's my intuition about why that works
and then also related to that correct me
from wrong in some of your relations in
the paper again some of this stuff up
the multiple layers we actually see that
you don't really need that many layers
of cross mentality because that's mostly
what we've done is we've turned the
vision problem into a language problem
and therefore we can do this appengine
know where where should I go where how
can I borrow the intuition that you have
about hospitality and then where can I
go from there to sort of actually make
progress on the sort of larger ground
new problem beyond kind of just how do i
encode this task into the same
vocabulary to run this model I see so if
I under correct understanding human
talent after that I don't like what is a
central part I can't answer so are you
are you like talking about why the model
learn these or wronging right or or more
generally right if we're gonna move so
you have you this intuition to introduce
this cross cross modal that's trying to
transform right okay and that's it
that's a great piece of intuition okay
then what we found right is that you
there's really not that much actual
grounding going on it's more that we
have we all need a couple layers of it
because we basically moved our our wives
into vocabulary using the detection
basically like words uh-huh yeah we
don't need that many layers so if in
your idealized version of what grounding
should look so it's a first thing yeah
the first things like shown here so
actually the gray vine is six layer on
BQ ASU so two layer is
actually perform really bad and but some
other tasks like refer expression or VCR
so we see our ABS all it looks like a
hard hats but in our experiment is like
it's kind of overfitting a lot it seems
like pretty easy so like to layer is
already do a really good job here so and
and because the reason we are developing
these variability is that we think
different tasks may require different
different level of like visual
processing of your abstraction layer so
so there's really not saying that ok
which two layers can be done running so
that's my first in term of your first
question and I think the second question
here is that so
what we are trying to build on these
papers before before this paper so there
is actually no kind of pre training or
like what has the motivation like like
kind of like for vision language Indomie
and language domain we learn this kind
of structure information by this /
tuning unlike some on some like
objective but but basically we are so
like essentially what we are learning
from vision language tasks is we want to
learn this kind of Association so if
we'll have a perfect visual conditions
right but as long as it's not high with
the caption word like cable it is not
useful to solve this task you make like
easily embed in some space but still
what we really want is to joint
understanding these two things so so so
so basically what we are trying to do is
we are trying to explore this like and
explore these directions and I think
this is a little initial stage so there
may be some more work and how to maybe
reduce how to learn better groundings
or some study on like whether he's
learning or not so I think there will be
later the publications trying to answer
this track and our favorite wounded in
the pre-training what you mayor steel
construction yeah
so we I didn't close out but we have a
task if we have a zero shot
image retrieval so baseless that if you
train on construction caption and you do
retrieval tasks because you have we have
this kind of predicting Alaia not right
so you just use the data score and you
big thing that that one like basely you
you're trying to do a richard has liquor
speak a we observed it can actually do a
pretty good job so beastly it learns
even like training on conception
captions that means it'll be different
from flickr Siddiq a data set but it can
actually learn to correctly like
retrieve the image so so but but yeah
but we don't have any other like about
apart from that we don't have any other
to measure whether you do a good job or
not yeah unfortunately so the number the
years is they cost more than you know
it's like obviously we fuse every layer
so you have to layer visual because we
have like a k layer of the vision of the
visual part we have our layer of the
text Roberge hear the case through but L
is always tell because we also use a
protein verdict so even do not really
true in the parent yeah wait wait wait
we fine-tune it so we're trying to fix
the parameter and actually the intuition
is if you fixing them because they are
initialized from a very good
pre-training
like large corpus it may be if you just
learned wrongly right just even part of
running it may be better but in ours
case fixing them actually leading our
experiment but if you want to trying to
train a model solving vision language
tasks and language test me tennis Lee
this is very useful because you are
trying to separate in those late and
building a connection between these two
you're having more weight which can do
each task like assumption that you're
making are not saying that it's
necessarily wrong okay you already have
a semantic representation of the vision
yeah you already have basically a
semantic representation of the language
yes and so then once those exist I can't
do this crossbow transfer yeah as a
child presumably I was learning both of
them simultaneously mmm
or was I not was it the case that I
actually built an entire visual
representation of the world first and
then I learned language basically like
is this the right sort of philosophical
way to be building grounded models or is
this the way that is the best for the
tasks that we have right
yeah I think I think I think I think
it's right this is actually a problem
rather than to some kind of new like
absolutely new structure that do this
simultaneously so in our case with even
really fun to millions of visual park so
if you punching this part you can think
okay you're trying to change everything
right but but but basically due to some
like competition like limited it we are
doing we didn't do this and also it's
also considered based on the performance
because because we are trying to using
the best of the visual representations
best of the language park to buildings
because we are thinking if you want to
understand visual language you have to
do we have we have to use the best of
both of them so and that's why we are
using existing system and trying to
build on top of it and not really having
a very new comment like novel which
didn't use any of them yeah and also did
you how about using other house I think
this reconstruction cottage correction
Academy inspired by perch much for
conceptual that's nation you know
captioned yeah I said oh it's a
reachable then I said we're not
directing just yet that's what people
caption ask us or appreciating yes it
has this kind of like image caption
alignment which but but yeah but I think
this is a very good point we also really
explore this last due to timing stuff
but but I think now we are trying these
theories are like no noise no noise
congestive estimation so like and say
you lost and visually is proposed by
video bird and we try that and seems
like we have positive results obviously
using that loss it will benefit from
task for a project for the visual
basically originally we are trying to
minimize a KO between the predictor the
other engine know like soft label with
their predict label right and now you
can replace that okay out average lost
razor and say you lost and using that
loss basically you know you are trying
to replace retrieve amongst is somehow
the negative regions and you are trying
to align them this - Liam better loss
for positioning has I think in our so we
are actually doing our current work yeah
for that and I can
usually Olivia later yeah
well so yeah so then like I'm going to
talk about the recent and future work
and once the work I'm like I'm going
work I'm doing now is the vision
language multitask learning so so
basically so for example if we see the
wheel bird is still like zero it's like
there might be still some inconsistency
grounding by tasks a big fine-tuning and
also be only involved for vision
language tasks and also the model is
huge we also observed there's
overfitting and some specific tasks but
suffice a movie CR and what we what we
want is we want more tasks and we want
consistent wanting the best even train
them to tune them together to use the
same representations and we want to
explore the limit of the model so
basically want to say how many it has we
can do for single model here so then
like we are trying to do this like one
model for all vision language tasks so
and now we are trying this tell tasks
here obviously we have this vqa refer
expression has been language that
verification has which is done by other
similar work and image description has
the basis difference here is that we're
trying to train this task to a multiple
burning so trendy stuff together and
what we are really interest is these
three things the first is we are
interesting benchmarking efficient
language to us understanding has in
Wilbert and we are we are interesting
studies this interconnection risk like
within task group or between high school
right so if you can trim them what's
happening or what is the best strategy
and what's also interesting this like is
if runway I the basically whether we can
use other tasks to output to output some
out to provide some explanations for the
for the class so for example like if the
vqa doing this wrong what about is a
refer expression
point in the right region so we are
interesting like to some analysis on
that which we can give us more than any
other model cool and there's another
project ongoing project I'm reading so
busy is called their log without the
airlock so the goal here is that we have
two agent and the two agents of an agent
only sees a pool of image presidencies
of four image so the green one and one
agents a red one sees only the target
image or the moon in this case is a
region like the third image
so what what your interest is that to
have a conversation between this to
agent and letting the agent to predict I
think the like the question agent to
predicting actually the goal here so
basically something like the agent will
ask is your child in your city and the
agent is answer laying and then leave me
pretty keen for and then like if we were
asking us a very low question something
like what is the color of the blanket
and it's answer right so then we can
correctly predict the the correct one is
three yeah it's very similar so but but
what people do here is people nearly
collecting like we have human and
hitters and collecting this data right
and then like we are trying to train the
agent with this data right so this is
what calm approach basically you are
collecting data for this goal in hit
area so for this goal and yeah and in
our case we are more interest in we are
not want to clicking data because
clicking it is expensive so can we just
use reward to happening like to to learn
this kind of data but but early like by
only injecting this reward because the
water is very sparse what we are what we
see that it will say something like what
color is easy so Beasley's if you buy us
Mother Language so our goal here is
whether we can learn both maintain the
language fluency and also also improve
the task performance like the cope like
the specific or performance here so what
we do is we want to learn the language
fluency from vqe so basically we want to
train a question board to ask questions
using the curator there's no history or
there's no dialogue contacts here and
the key insight is that we want to use
the language model with this critic let
an action space and if we see these two
questions and then like if we
interpolate in this discrete Latin
action space what we observe is it can
has we have these nice properties that
it have these nice transitions between
different questions right so because
like something like it can actually
literally fall in to generate like a
weird weird question or like a nonhuman
question
and then the second key insight is for
tests for like improving the test
performance by open tuning we want to do
like results for getting the language
and we are reinforced two discreet
lessons action space instead of you are
having the reward on the speaker here so
basically were directly renovating the
action the destination space here and by
doing this we have some initial result
so with the agent
so with agent training on vqa so it's
using a bqa and we're actually using
this aw8 it so this is anymore in the
valve so business is a different domain
of with your image Akemi needs to to
image the question the question
bottomless is to image and the essent
and answer box is a target image so the
so this is actually result where you are
seeing those question bosses how many
paths are in the photo and the answer is
one because the answer bar is not
accurate right you can make essentially
it will be worse on the timing problem
and it actually give you a wrong answer
so the question about sim predicting
button so suppose oh I suppose the
target is zero and is actually putting
this one and then it's going to ask
another question like what color is
under like it's on your body penis
animal and it's going to answer like a
prom so if you keep giving a wrong
answer now and it's do predicting one
here and then like it's asking what
color is a deeper fur so there's
actually a mistake here but I think the
go here is the question agents want to
asking the further we can kind of
understand it's asking the fur of this
animal and it actually answers black and
white and then it actually doing this
job correctly so the goal here is that
we are using the cure data and we're
trying to do this door and hit dialogue
really by only it has busy fine-tuning
without any of the human clackett the
data set data
I'm telling answers I'm genuine
questions and I'm fine tuning on this go
I'm fine tuning question bar on this you
don't have any I'll a port a body is a
big way this is the ecosystem is fixed
vacuity system is not punching yeah
that's it
yeah and in terms of the future interest
I'm interesting this multimodal
repetition learning envision language
sound and action basically different
domain the reason is because the
environment around us is not any model
right so for example give this table
concept we can say is this kind of
visual visual visual representation
visual appearances it can be something
like if you knock the table and if you
have some sound here and also you can
providing some kind of high level high
level like the table is providing a
level of surface which complex made up
placed so what we really want is learner
representations that connect all these
modalities and then it will give us a
more complete understanding of the
environment so I'm also interested in
this emerging of goal-oriented dialogue
with natural language and dialogue is
the most natural way to communicate
right and but it is really impossible to
collect their share of data for all the
Darryl class right if you want to
collect one peeled egg or go godello
system it is really impossible to click
it upon other goals so what I'm really
interested is that we are going to study
this kind of emerging of language or it
may like yes so we have some work in
this emerging of language and emergent
machine code but this is not useful
because people cannot understand it
right those code although machine
although this call may be conditionally
conditional but it's not useful so
people cannot understand them and what
I'm really interest is I'm interests in
emerging strategy so that I'm interests
in this emerging of language that human
can understand so we want to consider in
the code in the space of human that
language in the language space and also
I'm interests in this common sense
abstraction and causal is me so because
I think this is an intrinsic motivation
behind the scene and and also there is
really emerging of the common sense and
reasoning of the of the motivation here
is really something we should abstract
behind the actual the world around us
and then like we can be with a more
human-like or more integrative agent
which can help people in the daily life
so this is something I'm really under
explored in my study in my PhD study but
this is my interest
future oh thank you I have a question a
new cloak of false Kevin so many future
inches
well for my understanding in your back
pocket it'll talk about wanting then you
talk about future you are interested in
all models and the in fact there's
another train design modular network of
modular models want you to know
different modules and yeah then in this
way you can also achieve some kind of
baby yeah I think we've had or you also
talk about reasoning yeah for all this
for kind of names they are as using I
think they are referring to the same
thing
yeah cuz they now they have different
cars they're very different businesses
if you just want to choose one caste but
then us on
maybe just one has which hasn't using
that will kind of Renaissance the idea
internal problem here and what do you
think it's an underdone problem how do
you other kind of major the progress of
that essential other nonprofit yeah yeah
yeah I think that's a really good point
because I think all all these different
approaches basically we are trying to
approach the same goal right we are
trying to solve the same go here so we
have this kind of huge pre-training are
using a huge builder huge model and
using like tons of data to preach in the
model we also has is like more
interpretive one where you have you like
something like modern work right and and
and I think for me
so actually I'm interest imposed but but
I think they have different properties
right because so it's a way of the
modular network is that now it can still
handle your very limited data right we
can still like ant Y data something like
right so so it cannot really handle the
real world problem and and actually we
want to solve the real problem and also
and this is a way of a benchmarking like
whether we are succeed or not right so
we all make progress on real-world
problem but we want to still benefit
from those kind of instinct from this
like motor network or those kind of pipe
problem so maybe we can if I can combine
these two ideas I think that will be
better but but I mean what I mean saying
that
really this is different properties are
different married proposed to see I have
a question regarding applications on all
this so what would be the application
that you would envision as being an
important application of this work
something that you know not just vision
research right with but it somebody will
actually paid for yep yeah so so I think
I think especially for vision language
class and now like there's not really a
lot of applications right for something
like the English captioning may be
useful for visually impaired people but
still a very constant domain right
because we are the system is not perfect
right sometimes produces our captions
but I think a long-term goal here is
that we want to sum them test bad right
based in testing whether the system is
intelligent or not and also I'm super
like I'm super interested in this
dialogue system so please Lee if so dare
loss system I think it's a nest thing
which we can making on production
so I'm interesting how to how to write
really learn this Goran hit airlock
without always with less supervision and
in like in in my table I'm talking about
this visual Darrow this this kind of gay
like image guy think I am gay of guess
what game kind of go but this goal can
be applied to any any other goal like
any other maybe that pure language space
there at all so so so yeah so what I
mean here that this is this is kind of
research problem study but but this may
be constraint here but we can use the
similar idea strategy applying on any
other of real problem is not to guess
which image your goal is the goal here
is guess image because the question boss
is the COO of image right
yes Lee you are going to predict if the
poo is for we are going to predict one
two three four and and then you are
going to get the loss or reward
[Applause]
you